précédemment sur DTC voilà c'est fait je
me suis fait opérer les yeux au laser
dans la vidéo précédente vous m'aviez
laissé sur la table d'opération après
mon intervention des yeux au laser que
s'est-il passé ensuite quels sont les
suites opératoires est-ce que ça fait
mal qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire et ne pas
faire quand on s'est fait opérer et puis
surtout et puis surtout est-ce que ça a
marché ouais non mais c'est moi qui fait
la voix OK et puis surtout est-ce que ça
marche toutes les réponses dans ce
nouvel épisode de DTC
c'est vrai
par moment là par exemple j'ai il faut
faire qu'il se ferme toute seule je dois
avoir l'air extrêmement ivre par contre
par contre là j'arrive à lire j'arrive à
lire mes sms même comme ça même comme ça
par contre ouais j'ai un petit voile
lourd et truc horrible des yeux qui se
ferme tout seul donc c'est pas très
agréable je dois être relativement
hideux
mais franchement c'est incroyable c'est
bon comme j'ai dit je suis content
d'avoir que deux yeux parce que c'est
pas si pas si agréable que ça
mais ça fait vraiment pas très mal alors
comment il va très bien ensuite
l'ophtalmo m'a refait des examens pour
s'assurer que tout allait toujours bien
bon j'avais un peu de mal à garder les
yeux ouverts
donc quand vous arrivez chez vous
comment demander il y a quatre colliers
différents vous allez avoir envie de
fermer les dieux il m'a donné quelques
conseils pour la nuit mettez bien de
l'école avant de dormir et demain matin
ça ira beaucoup mieux et puis je suis
rentré chez moi voilà je rentre chez moi
je vous cache pas que je vis pas mon
meilleur moment je vous raconterai un
petit peu les sensations quand je serai
au chaud et quand je me serais remis des
gouttes anesthésiante parce que là ça ça
picote je me souvenais vu le petit style
là les lunettes de soleil de protection
je sais pas si je ressemble je sais pas
si je ressemble à une rock star ou
Philippe Manoeuvre
ou juste un dealer mais ça fait un petit
style je pleure abondamment également ok
donc de retour à la maison
alors bonne nouvelle je n'ai pas toussé
c'est vrai qu'à un moment je me suis dit
si je tousse pendant l'opération
est-ce que ça a pas craindre je n'ai pas
pété comme vous avez pu le constater
mais du coup j'ai eu peur de me
contracter à mort pour me retenir de
tousser et que du coup je pète voilà
enfin ce n'est pas toussé comme vous
avez pu le constater et croyez-moi sur
parole je n'ai pas pété non plus
donc c'est franchement ça a été
là je vous cache pas que
c'est assez désagréable
comme sensation
alors en termes de vision c'est nickel
j'ai vraiment j'arrive à lire mon
téléphone sans lunettes enfin ses
lunettes de soleil que vous voyez là
j'ai quand même la vue un peu voilée
j'ai un petit voile devant les yeux
je renifle énormément parce que je on
m'a mis plein de gouttes pendant
l'opération et je m'en suis remis depuis
et ils m'ont donné des gouttes
anesthésiantes qui pour supporter la
douleur et tout donc je vais vraiment
j'ai eu plein de gouttes et les yeux et
le nez ça communique c'est pour ça que
on renifle quand on pleure bah là du
coup j'aurais pas de renifler et puis
bah douleur quand même ça fait pas hyper
mal mais
déjà le en fait le plus désagréable
c'est cette sensation que vos yeux ont
tout le temps envie de se fermer et
d'ailleurs il se ferme assez
régulièrement je sais pas si vous voyez
comment on se prend une Poussière dans
l'oeil ou quand on se met le doigt dans
l'oeil ou un truc comme ça on a les yeux
qui se ferment tout le monde seul on
n'arrive pas à les garder ouvert on a
les yeux qui pleurent machin et tout bah
là c'est comme ça mais un peu en
permanence donc pas ouf
donc c'est pas une vraie douleur mais
c'est une gêne un peu permanente c'est
pas génial pour le moment
normalement ça devrait passer demain
matin et il faudra que je mette aussi
mes coques de protection je vous
montrerai ça parce que je pense que ça
va être vraiment très joli ça a beaucoup
mieux dernière petite chose à faire
avant de dormir
mettre mes coques de protection pour la
nuit
aïe
j'ai cassé mes lunettes de soleil
je suis un petit peu allergique au
sparadraps celui-là c'est normalement
c'est de l'hypergénique mais peut-être
demain matin j'aimerai me réveiller
extrêmement boursouflé voilà donc
première nuit passée vous avez vu la
soirée pas si ouf le médecin est
prescrit le paracétamol codéiné en cas
de besoin j'ai pris juste du paracétamol
j'ai regretté je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
fait le malin alors que je vous dis
toujours il y a pas de gloire à souffrir
j'aurais dû prendre du de la codéine
clairement c'est pas si douloureux mais
c'est quand même vraiment gênant bon
hier la vision c'était quand même pas
ouf cette nuit j'ai très bien dormi je
me suis réveillé à 4h du matin parce que
je m'étais couché très tôt il m'est
arrivé un truc que je craignais un petit
peu parce que ça mettait déjà arrivé
quand je m'étais fait une petite plaie
de la de la cornée justement parce que
donc c'est la cornée qui a été opérée
c'est à dire que quand je me suis
réveillé à 4h du mat j'ai voulu ouvrir
les yeux et c'était un peu collé à
l'intérieur vous savez quand comme quand
vous avez une plaie
sur la peau et que ça colle un peu au
draps du lit et quand vous bougez ça ça
s'arrache un peu voilà c'est pas hideux
mais quand même quand j'ai ouvert les
yeux j'ai senti que ça
et après j'ai eu l'oeil sur tout l'œil
gauche parce que c'est l'oeil gauche sur
tout qui me et je vous expliquerai après
pourquoi l'oeil gauche est différent de
l'oeil droit mais donc l'oeil gauche
surtout à bien accroché et ça s'est mis
à pleurer ça c'est remis à me faire mal
alors que j'avais plus mal donc j'ai eu
un peu de mal à me rendormir après mais
je me suis mis des gouttes là
d'irrigation et ça a été quand même là
ce matin au réveil c'est c'est très très
net très flagrant que j'ai comme je vous
l'expliquerai plus tard un oeil qui voit
de près et l'autre œil qui voit de lien
de loin donc c'est un peu particulier
pour l'instant j'ai encore un voile
devant les yeux mais c'est normal la
cornelle a été opérée c'est tout frais
donc c'est encore un peu traumatisé et
encore une fois sur tout l'oeil gauche
qui est donc je vois un peu
voilé voilà pas vraiment flou mais
voilée par contre je peux d'ores et déjà
envoyer des messages parce que j'ai pas
manqué de faire pour rassurer mes
proches que je peux envoyer des messages
aux gens sans mettre mes lunettes là là
mes lunettes je m'en suis pas servi
depuis le retour de la de l'opération là
pour vous expliquer un peu j'ai quand
même des soins pendant un bon petit bout
de temps donc vous avez vu les coques
que j'ai mis hier en fait faut surtout
pas que je me frotte les yeux pour pas
là il y a quand même le la surface de la
cornée qui a été découpé rabattu pour
passer le laser puis remise par dessus
on va cette ce petit capot de cornet
faut qu'il se recolle donc faut pas que
je touche et bah la nuit on contrôle pas
trop ces mouvements c'est pour ça qu'il
faut mettre des coques c'est pour éviter
déjà les frottements dans l'oreiller et
puis il faut éviter de se frotter les
yeux sans faire attention la nuit donc
faut pas que je touche à mes yeux du
tout
sauf pour faire les soins évidemment
mais délicatement je mets les coques la
nuit pendant une semaine et j'ai un bon
paquet de gouttes je vais vous montrer
tout ça voilà donc j'ai tout ça
ça c'est le petit collyre d'irrigation
là qui m'ont donné hier à la clinique
pour soulager un petit peu mes yeux donc
ça je vais pas m'en servir pendant
longtemps a priori ça c'est pour me
nettoyer délicatement les cils
délicatement parce que faut pas que je
me frotte les yeux donc faut que je
fasse tout doucement ça c'est matin et
soir c'est l'antibiotique que j'avais
commencé avant en prévention ça je
continue encore pendant trois jours et
puis ces trois là je les continue
ensuite pendant trois semaines quatre
fois par jour ça c'est les larmes
artificielles que je mettais aussi en
prévention donc c'est pour bien hydrater
la cornée etc ça c'est un lubrifiant
oculaire donc un petit peu le même
principe c'est pour bien
bien hydrater bien lubrifié le mon œil
et ça c'est un anti-inflammatoire qui a
aussi une action antibiotique donc c'est
pour éviter l'inflammation c'est pour
éviter que l'oeil s'infecte parce que
c'est une des une des complications
post-opératoires donc normalement si je
fais tout ça bien
pas de problème et après pendant trois
mois je continuerai à mettre juste le
lubrifiant oculaire voilà donc
évidemment je fais tout bien comme il
faut et là je vais je vais me doucher et
je vais retourner voir le docteur
Bokobza qui m'a qui m'a opéré hier pour
la visite de contrôle à J+1 puisque on
est à J+1 donc tu vas me dire a priori
il m'a dit hier déjà que tout était bien
passé mais là il va vérifier que c'est
toujours le cas et que il y a pas de il
y a pas eu de souci pendant la nuit je
pense que ça va être vite fait ok je
suis en route pour la consultation
post-opératoire
comme j'ai cassé mes lunettes de soleil
hier j'en ai mis des nouvelles vous avez
vu à sorti à mon sweat certaines idées
de la classe maintenant parce que je
sais pas si vous j'ai une vue presque
parfaite maintenant donc je suis très
attentif à tous ces petits détails par
contre je suis toujours daltonien je
disais peut-être ça va non ça n'a rien
changé
et retour chez l'ophtalmo donc il a
checké ma vision sans lunettes de près
avec des textes des cris de plus en plus
petit et le verdict est tombé
avec mon doigt ensuite il a checker ma
vision de loin même principe mais avec
des lettres et puis bah de loin du coup
et verdict
sur 10 après il a vérifié que ma cornée
elle est bien et puis il m'a redonné
quelques consignes et il m'a demandé si
j'étais content
je suis très content
de chercher mes lunettes alors que j'en
ai pas besoin quoi alors très content
il est content j'étais content bon le
médecin m'a confirmé que effectivement
l'opération c'est très bien passé
tout ce que je ressens depuis
et normal donc pas de pas d'inquiétude
en vrai de toute façon ça va là ça va
vraiment beaucoup mieux il m'a donné
rendez-vous dans 4 mois pour un contrôle
si je fais bien le traitement à la
lettre devrait pas y avoir de souci donc
c'est parfait et puis les petits les
petits inconvénients visuels que j'ai là
le petit voile qui a presque
complètement disparu à vrai dire c'est
normal aussi ça va se ça va se
s'arranger dans les dans les semaines
qui qui viennent ok J+2 maintenant
petit point par point la douleur
franchement pratiquement plus rien
petite gêne comme si j'avais un petit
truc dans l'oeil par moment ça passe
vraiment bien avec les gouttes donc
vraiment pas un problème au niveau de la
vision en fait la il y a deux aspects il
y a la manière dont je vois donc là
c'est encore un peu trouble par moment
surtout l'oeil gauche encore une fois je
vais me poser un moment et je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi les deux yeux sont
pas pareil on va prendre le temps je
fais pas ça à la maintenance mais je je
prendrai je prendrai le temps de bien
vous expliquer parce que c'est la
presbytie encore une fois c'est
particulier donc c'est surtout le gauche
qui est encore un petit peu gêné je
pense pour plusieurs raisons en gros
j'ai un peu l'impression je sais pas si
vous avez déjà eu un un espèce de caca
d'oeil mais dans l'oeil oui ça vous ça
vous trouble un peu c'est pas
franchement vous voyez pas complètement
flou mais il y a un truc à la fois qui
vous gêne un petit peu et qui vous fait
voir un peu pas très net quoi donc j'ai
un peu ça à gauche à droite nickel donc
ça c'est pour la netteté globale autre
petit trouble un petit peu de de la de
la vision j'ai ce qui s'appelle des halo
je vois des halo lumineux c'est quelque
chose qui est a priori assez courant et
qui régresse normalement au bout de de
quelques temps
pour vous expliquer en gros exemple
précis j'ai pris le métro hier bah les
une contestation de loin je les vois je
les lis très bien sauf que quand il y a
le petit point lumineux allumé en
dessous bah il y a une espèce d'auréole
autour qui est le fameux halo lumineux
que je vois qui pour le coup m'empêche
de lire le texte qu'il y a au dessus
parce que ça parasite donc voilà petit
petit halo lumineux j'ai des potes qui
m'ont dit que ça leur avait fait la même
chose d'ailleurs je vous raconterai
aussi à un autre moment les témoignages
d'autres amis à moi qu'on fait d'autres
opérations mais avec la même enfin pour
d'autres troubles de la vision la myopie
en l'occurrence genre j'ai discuté avec
deux qui ont fait chacun une technique
différente donc ça peut être ça peut
être intéressant et donc c'est des voilà
effectivement c'est des choses qui leur
est arrivé aussi normalement sa régresse
reste à voir au bout de combien de temps
c'est pas c'est pas si gênant mais il y
a quand même un truc avec la avec la
luminosité
quand il fait un peu sombre et qu'il y a
des lumières un peu vives c'est ça peut
être compliqué après pour la vision j'ai
pas mis mes lunettes depuis l'opération
alors que vraiment avant j'étais
incapable de lire un SMS sans mes
lunettes je les ai pas remis donc c'est
vraiment immédiatement une telle
opération m'a vu était corrigée mon
trouble de la vision ma presbytie était
corrigée pour des raisons que je vous
expliquerai un peu plus tard j'ai encore
ces difficultés d'adaptation d'un œil à
l'autre parce que c'est un peu un peu
différent mais je vous expliquerai ça
bon c'est beaucoup de gouttes c'est pas
mal de sens c'est des gouttes je vous ai
dit 4 fois par jour
en technique je suis je suis au top
maintenant vraiment j'arrive à me les
mettre directement dans l'oeil sans sans
en de trois à côté avant plutôt
plutôt pas mal en plein de dons du
premier coup donc voilà franchement
c'est bien c'est c'est
là franchement logiquement ça aurait été
aujourd'hui le jour où j'aurais pu
reprendre le boulot je pense que oui
alors après moi je travaille beaucoup
sur écran j'imagine que c'est le cas de
beaucoup de gens hier j'ai fait du des
rushs de l'opération de la vidéo que
vous avez déjà vu du coup pendant une
heure à la fin ça tirait un peu et je
voyais un peu flou donc je pense qu'une
journée sur écran quand même 48 heures
après c'est chaud mais bon hier c'était
censé être la journée de repos après
l'opération aujourd'hui peut-être
la télé bizarre genre pour ces histoires
de la commodation je vais au cinéma tout
à l'heure je vous raconterai demain
comment ça s'est passé mais globalement
voilà pas mal j'ai pas du tout pris de
d'antidouleur je mets juste mes gouttes
mes coques oculaires la nuit pareil j'ai
pris des petits skills première fois
c'était pas ouf petites allergies et au
sparadrap là ça mérite un peu la peau
mais franchement ça va franchement on
est pas mal je vais au cinéma
et je vous raconte je vous raconte la
suite des événements
alors J+3
déjà le cinéma je suis allé au cinéma je
vous avais dit hier bah impeccable
quelques quelques minutes d'adaptation
parce que il y a toujours ce truc de la
vision dans le noir avec des trucs très
lumineux un peu complexes un peu comme
quand on regarde un film en 3D de 3
minutes d'adaptation et puis après ça va
c'est tranquille donc ça c'était plutôt
la Bonne Nouvelle
mon globalement ça continue ça suit son
petit bonhomme de chemin la petite gêne
toujours mais rien de méchant en termes
de un peu cette sensation d'avoir des
poussières dans l'oeil normal à priori
ça va ça va durer quelques jours mais
bon faut savoir que ça ça arrive
démangeaisons des trucs comme ça des
fois ça tire un peu des fois voilà
j'ai je me suis pris hier soir à me
frotter les yeux par une advance qui est
vraiment super super pas à recommandé
tout le monde a bien insisté là-dessus
donc j'étais pas tranquille mais bon a
priori tout va bien petit par contre toi
et petit inconvénient mais là on y peut
rien c'est vraiment ça ça tient à ma à
mon à ma peau je vous avais dit j'avais
peur de faire une réaction au sparadrap
bah voilà je crois qu'on y est là j'ai
laissé les lumières parce que j'ai
tourné un truc là j'étais obligé de
tourner 3/4 parce que parce que pour
m'acheter le masquer la misère mais vous
voyez ça se voit un petit peu là mais
moi donc là c'est le sparadrap et des
coques que je mets la nuit je vous ferai
quand même un petit tuto parce que il y
a une manière de les mettre pour que ce
soit moins gênant quand même je ferai un
petit tuto tout à l'heure en allant me
coucher voilà mise à part ça toujours
les petites bah voilà faut que je
m'habitue à ma nouvelle à ma nouvelle
vision mais tout va bien enfin bref ça
continue à aller pas trop mal ce soir
petit tuto coco culler demain je prends
le temps je me pose et je prends le
temps de vous expliquer la particularité
de l'opération que j'ai eu à savoir
l'opération pour la presbytie je vous en
ai je vous ai déjà attisé ça un petit
peu voilà vous verrez demain pourquoi
c'est un petit peu un petit peu
particulier ok alors comme promis le
petit tuto pour mettre ses coques
oculaires si vous vous faites opérer
[Musique]
ça se présente sous cette forme donc je
vous rappelle l'idée c'est de pas se
gratter se pas se frotter les yeux
pendant la nuit sans le vouloir et donc
l'idée c'est de mettre comme ça donc
faut cliquer ça sur les parties osseuses
pas sur les parties molles les parties
osseuses étant
voilà ici plancher de l'orbite
au dessus là au niveau du sourcil et le
nez voilà faut pas mettre ça sur l'oeil
il faut mettre ça vraiment reposer comme
ça et mettre les deux de chaque côté
après l'idée c'est peut-être cool un de
passe arracher les poils de de réussir à
voir quand même donc vu que le sparadrap
n'est pas transparent bah faut essayer
d'éviter de mettre ça sur les sur les
parties enfin de trop amputer le champ
visuel donc de mettre ça plutôt un peu
sur le côté et pas en dessous comme je
l'avais fait la dernière fois ou trop au
milieu voilà bon l'idée c'est de
tâtonner après en plus comme on fait ça
en général sans trop sans trop se voir
c'est pas forcément hyper facile un ou
deux petits tips premier siècle
sparadrap
si vous voulez pouvoir l'enlever à peu
près facilement une fois que ce soit
terminé
faites un petit repli comme ça ici
coller le sparadra sur lui-même comme ça
ici ça va pas coller et à l'endroit où
vous le mettrez vous pourrez à retirer
et décoller sans avoir à gratter avec
les ongles et à risquer de vous de vous
griffer la joue et puis pour les
décoller on décolle pas du sparadrap
comme ça on arrachant on décolle
toujours du sparadrap en faisant ce
qu'on appelle un contrepoint
c'est-à-dire le sparadray va venir se
coller là vous tirez la peau ici et vous
prenez le sparadra là et après vous
tirez et puis pour monter et vous tirez
comme ça voilà maintenant mettre la
coque en elle-même moi je le fais
allongé parce que comme ça j'ai juste à
poser la coque et j'ai pas la tenir je
peux me servir de mes deux mains vous
pouvez faire comme vous voulez moi je
trouve que ça marche bien comme ça je
vous montre
voilà je mets la première coque ce truc
là vers l'intérieur je pose ça sur le
plancher
au niveau des sourcils si ça recouvre
les sourcils ça veut dire que quand je
vais venir mettre du sparadra ici je
vais pas coller le sourcil avec donc
c'est plutôt pas mal et je colle les
sparadra ici
de manière à pas trop amputer mon champ
visuel donc le premier sparadrap on a
bien fait
petit truc pour le retirer facilement
après
[Musique]
je suis pas trop fort parce que vous
allez voir le matin ça fait un peu des
marques
[Musique]
qui commencent pas fou un peu les mettre
plus en des fois je les mets plus en
travaillant comme ça mais moi j'y vois
clair et c'est juste pour dormir toute
façon j'ai connu mieux en vrai
salut bien dormi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon vous avez vu c'est moche mais ça a
tenu quoi c'était le principal allez on
va enlever ça donc je vous ai dit là
vous avez eu petite languette hop ah
j'ai mis un peu sur la barbe ici pas fou
on tire la peau hop on vient l'attendre
et un petit coup sec
une
par ici on tire on tend un petit coup
sec
[Musique]
ça donne un terme de c'est toujours pas
mal ça
les bonnes petites traces du matin ah
ouais on adore
je vais prendre un café c'est peut-être
le moment de faire un de dresser un
premier petit bilan
en termes de douleur d'abord bon bah
j'ai quasi vraiment plus rien très
rapidement c'est passé là j'ai vraiment
des petites gènes par moment mais qui
passe très vite quand je mets des
gouttes donc vraiment quasi aucune
douleur j'ai pris ma petite routine vous
avez vu ça les coques la nuit les
gouttes la journée tout ça voilà j'ai
pris j'ai pris une petite habitude donc
à ce niveau là pas de souci après petit
truc
l'effet waouh et un peu passé j'ai été
vraiment
ultra bluffé en sortant à peine du bloc
opératoire de voir que je pouvais tout
de suite regarder mon téléphone portable
que je pouvais lire les papiers qui
m'avaient donné pour les rendez-vous du
lendemain etc ce petit cet effet waouh
cette lune de miel avec ma nouvelle
vision et un peu passée et je crois que
j'en suis au stade de notre couple avec
ma nouvelle vision et moi ou je commence
à juste à être un petit peu agacer ah
bah par les petits trucs qui voilà du
coup j'ai un peu moins de patience
maintenant je me suis habitué très vite
au fait de de lire sans lunettes même si
je les cherche encore régulièrement dans
mes poches le fait est que je me suis
très vite habitué à ne plus lire avec
avec mes lunettes et comme je me
souviens plus du tout de comment je
voyais avant quand je les avais pas bah
là je suis un peu agacé par moment
d'avoir du mal un peu à faire la mise au
point etc parce que ça évidemment ça
persiste le voile devant les yeux etc
tout est passé ce qui je suis encore
dans la phase où je dois m'habituer à ma
nouvelle vision et c'est peut-être
l'occasion de faire un petit point sur
cette nouvelle vision parce que comme je
vous l'avais déjà dit l'opération de la
presbytie c'est un truc un petit peu
particulier par rapport à la myopie
l'hypermétropie ou la stigmatisme ou là
on corrige un trouble au niveau de la
cornée là c'est pas c'est pas exactement
comme ça que ça se passe donc peut-être
que c'est le moment de rentrer un petit
peu dans les détails de cette opération
particulière qui est l'opération de la
presbytie le problème de la presbytie
vient pas de la cornée mais du
cristallin le cristallin il a perdu de
sa souplesse avec l'âge il arrive plus à
faire l'autofocus et ça se manifeste par
des problèmes d'accommodation on a du
mal à avoir de de près du coup on
éloigne le bras voilà on y arrive pas
dans l'état actuel des choses on ne peut
pas modifier le cristallin on peut pas
lui rendre son élasticité ni avec le
laser ni avec quoi que ce soit d'autre
donc l'opération particulière que j'ai
subi que la même que pour tous les
autres presbytes c'est la suivante on
détermine d'abord quel est mon oeil
dominant pour ça on m'a donné un
appareil photo et on m'a dit
spontanément comme ça vous utiliseriez
qu'à l'oeil pour prendre une photo en ce
qui me concerne c'est mon œil droit donc
on s'est dit cet œil là ça va être
l'oeil qui va voir de loin
donc ils m'ont corrigé à cet oeil là la
vision de loin qui pour moi était très
bonne et qui maintenant est devenu
parfaite grâce à l'opération donc ça
c'est cool et ben mon à gauche ils l'ont
opéré pour que sa vision soit parfaite
de près et c'est pour ça que j'ai pas
tout à fait les mêmes sensations au
niveau des deux yeux en post-op l'oeil
de droit c'était plus léger j'ai eu
l'impression l'oeil gauche c'était un
peu plus compliqué c'était un peu plus
douloureux c'était aussi plus difficile
à s'habituer et là maintenant ce qui se
passe c'est que pour être très concret
j'ai l'œil droit qui voit très bien de
loin mais pas bien de près et l'oeil
gauche qui voit très bien de près mais
pas bien de loin maintenant c'est à mon
cerveau de jouer mon cerveau il va
devoir automatiquement choisir de
sélectionner l'image la plus claire
quand je regarde de loin il va devoir
s'habituer à ne garder que l'image de
mon œil droit et à occulter celle de mon
à gauche et inversement quand je regarde
de près une petite gymnastique que mon
cerveau est en train de s'habituer à
faire pour l'instant c'est pas parfait
c'est pour ça que j'ai encore des
difficultés c'est pour ça que j'ai
encore ce truc un petit peu dés qui
m'agace voilà mais je sais que c'est
normal je sais que ça va passer donc le
médecin m'a dit effectivement vous allez
vous habituer votre cerveau va
s'habituer à cette petite gymnastique
mais dans un premier temps
il favorise un œil mais il garde encore
un petit peu l'image de l'autre donc
vous pouvez avoir cette impression de
voir un peu double d'avoir des images un
peu parasites etc donc voilà il m'a
conseillé aussi d'éviter de ce qui est
un réflexe de fermer un œil par exemple
de fermer l'oeil droit quand je veux
regarder quelque chose de près c'est sûr
que là si je fais comme ça je vois
nickel avec mon œil gauche de près si je
fais comme ça bon bah voilà faut que je
m'habitue à l'inverse si je veux
regarder un truc de loin si je ferme mon
œil là comme ça je vois impeccable mais
si je fais ça je n'habitue pas mon
cerveau à faire lui-même le choix donc
il faut éviter de faire ce genre de
choses voilà donc ça c'est pour mon
opération très particulière après il y a
ces histoires de halo lumineux donc je
vous ai déjà parlé qui vont qui vont
disparaître a priori il y a pas de souci
j'ai parlé à deux amis
qui ont eu eux une opération pour la
myopie Marinette Perrin que vous
connaissez peut-être qui est journaliste
spécialisé dans les sujets féministes
qui elle a eu le premier type
d'opérations pour une myopie la PKR et
Maxime Muscat mon camarade qui estimer
que vous connaissez aussi sans doute qui
lui a eu l'autre opération pour la
myopie c'est à dire la même que moi par
le même chirurgien d'ailleurs donc le
lassique bon bah eux m'ont confirmé à
peu près ce que j'avais dit dans la
première vidéo c'est à dire Marinette
a eu du mal en post-op immédiat ça a été
plus douloureux elle a mis un peu plus
de temps à y voir clair là où Maxime a
vécu à peu près la même chose que moi
c'est-à-dire un peu compliqué
les premières heures après l'opération
et puis dès le lendemain au réveil
magique quoi sauf que eux n'ont pas eu
cette histoire de
s'habituer à avoir un oeil qui voit bien
au loin un œil qui voit bien après parce
que maintenant leurs yeux sont
son nickel quoi
autre avantage qu'ils ont eux par
rapport à moi c'est que la chirurgie de
la myopie a priori si on vous la fait un
moment votre myopie est stable et là
c'est définitif vous n'avez plus jamais
besoin de vous faire opérer vous avez
une bonne vision jusqu'à ce que
éventuellement vous commencez à devenir
presbyte parce qu'avec l'âge tout le
monde y passe mais en tout cas pour la
myopie c'est définitive plus besoin d'y
toucher moi en ce qui me concerne j'ai
fait l'opération un peu tôt voilà on a
tendance à penser que vers 55 60 ans
la presbytie se stabilise mais qu'avant
elle continue à dégénérer ce qui fait
que moi potentiellement c'est pas
terminé mais on parlera de ça à la fin
quand on fera le quand on fera le bilan
total
à la fin de la fin de cette petite
semaine post-opératoire
hop aujourd'hui le programme c'est la
reprise du sport j'ai le droit j'ai
demandé on peut reprendre le sport tout
de suite en déconcent dès qu'on sort
d'attaque on peut même aller courir je
vais aller courir après seul truc auquel
il faut faire attention c'est pas de
sport violent pas de sport avec des
contacts notamment au niveau du visage
si vous faites du rugby si vous faites
de la boxe si vous faites je sais pas du
foot des sports ou potentiellement il
peut y avoir un contact un peu violent
non pas tout de suite par contre fitness
et compagnie aucun souci en fait ce
qu'il faut éviter c'est vous voyez le
petit capot qui a été découpé la guerre
abattu pendant l'opération bah toute la
convalescence ça consiste à le laisser
cicatriser en fait donc bah le risque
c'est qu'il se redécole du coup attendre
que ça se remette bien en espérant en
plus que ça se recale bien comme il faut
éviter la piscine aussi faut pas ouvrir
les yeux sous l'eau d'ailleurs faut
faire attention quand on se douche la
douche c'est ok le bain c'est ok mais il
faut juste pas que l'eau rentre dans le
dans les yeux donc il faut fermer les
yeux tout simplement après qui prend sa
douche les yeux ouverts
et blague à part si on se met du savon
ou du shampoing dans les yeux il faut
bien se rincer avec les gouttes que que
le médecin a prescrit faut faire faut
faire gaffe faut faire gaffe à tout ça
donc pas de piscine pas de sport violent
pas de sport avec contact
évitez globalement de se cogner la tête
violemment voilà c'est les petits
conseils mets le sport pas de souci donc
voilà c'est parti bon on a fait un petit
saut dans le temps là parce qu'on est à
j+12 maintenant ça fait presque deux
semaines j'ai même eu le temps d'aller
chez le coiffeur je pense que c'est le
moment de faire un petit bilan la
douleur déjà bah franchement plus rien
c'est le truc qui passe le plus
facilement en quelques heures c'est
c'est fini on en parle plus pour ce qui
est de la vue les petits troubles
visuels que j'avais au début bah le
voile il y a plus rien du tout c'est
passé très très rapidement aussi il me
reste encore vous savez ces histoires de
Halo dont je vous ai parlé c'est encore
un petit peu compliqué quand il y a des
trucs très lumineux surtout la nuit mais
sinon ça va et pour la vision pure et
dure maintenant et ben nickel je lis
sans lunettes et ça c'est cool parce que
j'adore lire
non franchement c'est un vrai
soulagement de plus de plus avoir besoin
de lunettes avant je pouvais absolument
pas m'en passer il fallait toujours que
je les ai sur moi ça fait d'ailleurs pas
si longtemps que ça que j'ai perdu le
réflexe de les chercher en permanence
dans mes poches là maintenant je n'en ai
plus du tout besoin je m'en suis
vraiment plus du tout servi depuis le
jour de l'opération
donc ce coup là
non j'ai une meilleure idée
je vais les envoyer à lunettes sans
frontières
d'ailleurs si vous aussi vous avez des
lunettes dont vous avez plus besoin vous
pouvez faire ça aussi je vous mets le
lien dans la description de la vidéo bon
alors sortie de ça faut encore quand
même que mon cerveau s'habitue à
switcher d'un œil à l'autre vous savez
en fonction de si je regarde quelque
chose de loin ou quelque chose de près
ça va mieux de près franchement j'ai
quasiment plus de soucis de loin j'ai
encore un petit temps d'adaptation au
cinéma par exemple il me faut 10 minutes
pour pour prendre l'habitude mais
franchement ça va déjà mieux apparemment
il faut 3 à 4 semaines pour qu'on arrive
à gérer ça vraiment correctement en fait
on s'y fait plus ou moins rapidement en
fonction de notre plasticité cérébrale
c'est comme ça que ça s'appelle en gros
c'est la capacité d'adaptation au
changement de notre cerveau et de nos
neurones on verra bien si mon cerveau
est souple je pense que je referai pas
forcément une vidéo pour vous raconter
ça dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent par contre je j'en parlerai
sans doute sur les réseaux sociaux donc
je vous invite à vous abonner tu connais
au final bah on verra bien comment tout
ça va évoluer mais pour l'instant
franchement en ce qui me concerne zéro
regret c'est vrai qu'à la base les yeux
ça peut faire un petit peu flipper les
yeux c'est quand même voilà dans les
films d'horreur on aime bien faire
flipper avec ça en plus c'est chargé de
plein de choses y compris symboliquement
c'est assez chargé les reflets de l'âme
tout ça donc donc on est voilà on est
jamais trop trop rassuré de se faire
triturer les yeux mais moi je l'ai
vraiment pris comme si j'allais prendre
l'avion c'est-à-dire ok ça se passe mal
ça craint vraiment mais ça se passe
quasi jamais mal donc ça va quoi alors
pour la petite blague j'avais quand même
demandé qu'on m'envoie des selfies que
mes proches soient que les gens
m'envoient des selfies de tels qui
voudraient que je me souvienne d'eux au
cas où je perds la vue donc ça m'est pas
arrivé mais j'ai des jolis petits
souvenirs
des beaux petits dossiers et puis pour
finir en parlant un petit peu d'avenir
bah vous souvenez je vous ai dit la
presbytie ça se stabilise vers 55 60 ans
donc il est pas impossible que je dois
retourner me faire opérer
l'ophtalmo m'a dit par exemple d'ici 6 7
ans c'est possible que ça ait déjà
suffisamment rebaissé pour que une
nouvelle opération soit nécessaire ou
que je décide juste de remettre des
lunettes c'est possible aussi donc il y
a pas d'obligation de se faire réopérer
mais la particularité de la presbytie
par rapport aux autres qui a priori a
priori sont définitives c'est que si on
se fait opérer disons avant 50 ans il y
a des chances de devoir y retourner au
moins une fois mais bon on n'y est pas
on parle de voilà si si 7 ans disons
d'ici là je vais vous refaire des vidéos
on va se remettre à parler d'autre chose
et puis comme d'habitude prenez soin de
vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez-vous bien et surtout
portez-vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]